make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay so we are picking back up with uh
swords of x and in this one we're
covering part four which features
x-force which is just kind of a
continuation of the video the the last
video that we did we were talking about
wolverine
right and in the last video wolverine
was on the hunt for muramasa right he
was traveling around
it's been about 24 hours doing it trying
to find this guy because it was his task
to locate and use the muramasa blade as
part of the swords of x event the thing
about this is that everybody that he'd
talked to
had basically told him that muramasa had
essentially become a servant of the hand
which was kind of a
something that wolverine just couldn't
really get behind right because muramasa
never really seemed to be the kind of
person
that would serve the hand but ultimately
locating this yomi temple that
celebrated the underworld he ended up
finding that muramasa had kind of been
sacrificed in this sort of ritual
sacrifice that
that had basically taken him to the hand
or at least been done by the hand and
that's when wolverine's completely and
totally ambushed right now the thing
about the hand and we've talked about
this before
because they use the attack in massive
droves right they attack in just a huge
overwhelming number basically means that
anybody they go against isn't really
going to have much of a chance to defeat
them now uh with regards to facing off
against wolverine they can hold their
own
well then you know more than enough
right because they're here to achieve a
particular goal now when wolverine rips
the mask off one of the members of the
hand they don't look the way they used
to
in the sense of the hand always looked
like people because they effectively
were people but
the idea is that wolverine is basically
taken by the hand themselves once he's
stabbed
and thrown in you know thrown through a
kind of portal that leads directly to
what is essentially hell now helen
marvel comics and we've talked about
this before the hell of marvel
comics is kind of like is a geographical
place right and you can kind of split it
up
based on different territories right and
so if we said if we use the united
states as an example which is not that
far-fetched and we said the united
states is hell then in turn what we
could do is we could say like
california is ruled by mephisto and
washington dc
is ruled by like you know dame damon
hellstrom and florida is ruled by
somebody else right that is all kind of
broken up into these different sections
marvel's never really consolidated this
they've never really answered the
question like what stops
the soul in the realm of mephisto from
wandering into the soul of damon
hellstrom and how does this kind of you
know unification and splitting of
factions among hell
work right and marvel never really
clarified that they kind of have a
little bit to a degree here and there
but by and large we don't really have a
kind of like
map in terms of how hell is laid out and
how this determining factor on who rules
what section how it's all kind of
solidified but the long and short of
this is that this is how wolverine ended
up in hell and basically clawed himself
out when he was moving you know and just
was nothing more than an adamantium
skeleton now one of you guys asked the
question how it is that wolverine can
move
when he's only a skeleton comic book
logic guys because you're not wrong
right you're not wrong if you say that
doesn't make any sense no person who's
just simply a skeleton could move
because there's no
no muscle no nerves none of that stuff
none of the components that the body
needs in order to be able to move right
i mean your muscles push and pull and
that's how you move and you know move
one leg in front of the other right in
order to walk in a forward direction
without that you can't move you would
just be laying there right so comic book
logic just kind of
take it for what it is but that's when
he's kind of set upon the hand as they
kind of exist here right as they exist
in this this sort of new realm you know
he's met by basically demons and so on
and all the while
you have muramasa crafting swords for
for the beast now the
beast is a character that the hand
basically worship and the beast is
largely responsible for the hand's
mystical abilities right the ability to
resurrect the dead different things like
that but the funny thing about it is
that the beast's location which is to
say the dimension in which he resides
had never been fully fleshed out in
marvel comics and the fact that this is
in hell
really basically shows us the beast is
one of the hell lords that are out there
right he's one of these demonic entities
that resides in the realm of hell and
presumably has his own little location
now we don't really know anything about
it but whatever the situation is
muramasa has been brought here because
he is viewed as being owed a debt to the
beast and the reason for that comes in
the nature of muramasa in the sense that
when when he's crafting a weapon he's
the greatest craftsman in all
on all of earth right he's the greatest
weapons maker on earth itself
but one of the things that makes him so
interesting is that he can actually take
a portion or
all of your soul and put it inside the
weapon he creates and what this has been
viewed as by the beast and presumably
other demonic entities is that he robbed
them of souls right beings who maybe
maybe like they made some kind of a pact
with mephisto and
and mephisto would take their soul when
they die but instead they end up having
their soul
placed inside the muramasa blade their
physical body will die but their soul
will be pl
will kind of exist inside this blade and
they'll never actually go to the realm
of mephisto right so he was kind of
cheated out of a bargain so to speak
where muramasa doesn't really ask too
many questions he doesn't really he
doesn't really have a checklist right
like okay uh please check off the demon
entities who sold you oh
it didn't really work that way and so he
doesn't really know but the result of
this is that he's being viewed as owing
a debt and that's why he's currently a
servant of the beast
because the beast is making good on the
death that he feels he's owed now for
wolverine himself he's basically thrown
inside of one of the cells in hell and
when that happens his body of course
kind of starts you know regrowing you
know
his bones and or at least his uh
skeleton and and you know muscles and
all kind of stuff kind of starts going
through that whole process but he's met
with the arrival of solemn now solemn of
course as most of you guys remember we
saw
in the last video and this was a guy who
was contacted by
by the horseman war and basically told
you have to go and grab one of the
muramasa blades or a blade from muramasa
in order to satisfy your role
as one of the people who are going to be
fighting against the heroes of krakowa
right as part of this exodus swords
event and so he basically ends up kind
of going on his journey
and and traveling and getting to that
location now how was it he actually got
here to hell
it's kind of given to us in a bit of a
flashback in the sense that he kind of
tells wolverine while his body's
restructuring he basically tells
wolverine that at some point along the
line once he left
the island of a really the land of
morocco he ended up traveling
to travel and see the oracle of morocco
and the oracle had been placed there
kind of banished there by her sister and
the result was that
solomon essentially cut this girl's head
off and then brought it to the oracle
and was like here's the payment that i
offer as tribute for
this kind of prophecy this you know
direction that i need to go in right
because it requires some kind of tribute
in order for you to get information from
the oracle and so the oracle basically
tells them like you are going to have to
travel to the realm of hell and you have
the the tools you need to do it right
the muramasa is currently
currently dead you cannot go and find
him on earth but what you have in your
possession this hellblade that you
possess
is a key it will allow you to access
hell but know that when you go there
you're not going to be able to find
miramasa on your own instead you're
going to have to seek out the man made
of metal and he will be your guide to
muramasa hence the reason why solemn's
here because he needs wolverine in order
to find a muramasa and so the funny
thing is that once wolverine emerges
once he kind of pops back and he's
totally healed he uses his adamantium
and tries to cut through the hell force
bars and it doesn't work and this is one
of only a handful of instances in marvel
comics when we're basically given a
material that's stronger than adamantium
right by and large adamantium is the
strongest material in marvel comics
right there are a couple things out
there
that might be stronger than adamantium
something like like thor's hammer but
even within the marvel universe
nothing can really cut through
adamantium or at least only one thinking
can really cut through adamantium but it
is essentially highly durable it can't
really be destroyed when it starts out
in a liquid state once it hardens and
solidifies it can't be returned back to
a liquid state again there are different
kind of weaknesses out there something
like anti-metal right so if you had like
an anti-metal blade it could cut through
uh um sorry adamantium not in the
traditional sense but because anti-metal
breaks down metal on the atomic level
so it's almost kind of like you're
you're cutting through it without
actually touching it if that makes any
sense but
you know this is one of these instances
where we've encountered yet something
else in marvel that's stronger than
adamantium and so what you end up
getting is this attempt by wolverine to
kind of take out solemn right because of
the stance of solemn is i'm here to get
the muramasa blade and wolverines here
for the same thing then ultimately they
would end up fighting over the sword
right so wolverine's like i'll just kill
you now and i won't have to worry about
it later but when he goes to to attack
solemn we end up finding the reason why
solemn
is kind of considered to be this
indestructible man is because his skin
is actually made of adamantium but at
the moment he and wolverine
effectively have to work together right
wolverine can't kill him and he needs
wolverine and so with that happening
they basically set off into the
hellforge itself right into the realm of
the beast
and once they locate him there's this
kind of ceremony taking place right this
marriage between what he calls his left
his red left hand and his red right hand
right seemingly his two most devoted
servants
and so as this marriage is taking place
this is why these swords of muramas were
being created right they were being done
for the purpose of honoring this kind of
ritual not only that he put the entirety
of his soul into these swords right he
says for you i put my very soul into
them right and so what this does is it
leads to
you know as part of this ritual it leads
to the beast basically instructing his
servants to kill muramasa and then to
basically absorb his soul
into the swords themselves now whether
or not this means muramasa can come back
we don't really know right it may be one
of these things where the the soul is
stuck inside the swords and we'll never
see it again right muramasa is dead for
all time we're not entirely sure here
but what we do know
is that with his soul being absorbed
into the swords it makes them
wildly powerful in the sense that when
you have uh solemn launching his attack
and destroying one of the red hands that
this leads to the to the other one
attacking him and in doing so
he starts to bleed and that's when the
revelation is given to him on behalf of
wolverine the muramasa blades can cut
through adamantium that's their purpose
but the original muramasa blade was
created or at least
done by wolverine with a portion of his
soul placed inside
so that the sword itself could cut
through wolverine's adamantium and
behead him if it needed to be done
and so with that being the case all
blades coming after have the ability to
cut through adamantium right so it's
basically a means by which wolverine and
solemn can kill each other because the
question leading up to this was that if
these two are going to end up doing
battle
solemn's skin is made of adamantium and
wolverine's bones are made of adamantium
how could they ever really kill each
other right they would just fight for
all eternity but the fact of their
blades that are able to cut through this
material means they can kill each other
and that's what the questions kind of
asked that the beast is killed pretty
quickly which is a little disappointing
but the question that's asked by solomon
is why should i give you this sword why
do that i have both katanas uh you know
i've i killed
both the bride and the groom i could
just take them for myself but it's the
nature of the exodus swords event that
wolverine needs a sword and that solomon
needs a sword and seemingly solemn is a
person who is very much
honor bound right he believes that if
they are going to fight each other
they're going to duel in the most
honorable way possible
and so what he tells wolverine is i will
give you this sword but i want a deal i
want something in return what this thing
is
we don't know instead all we end up
getting next is wolverine emerging you
know into
into kakoa bringing his sword with him
simply saying that he got a sword but it
came with a price and then taking his
place on the altar as one of the heroes
who have attained their swords from the
exo-sword event but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end
if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you